étranger
[Musique]
nous sommes arrivés les perturbateurs ont réuni
un gang de bienvenue nous avons passé un excellent week
-end une gratitude d'être ici quand le mystère du meurtre
commence
Je vous ai tous invités à mon île salut
parce que ce soir un meurtrier
commettra mon meurtre une fois que vous '  re morts
pourrons-nous toujours vous parler
ouais je ne fais pas le mort tout le
week-end mec c'est vraiment délicieux à
travers l'île que des indices cachés vous
devrez vous observer de près
si quelqu'un peut nommer le tueur cette
personne gagne notre  jeu toutes les questions
qui ont un coup de pied
police
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs
pour au moins une personne ce n'est pas un
jeu
je dois insister pour que personne ne touche le corps
geez détective qui a tué la fête
je dois trouver un motif de meurtre
tout le monde poignarderait un  ami à l'arrière
pour s'accrocher à ce bâtard riche
vous êtes tous amis pourquoi quelqu'un
commettrait-il un meurtre
allons-nous même parler de l'
éléphant dans la pièce
suis-je l'éléphant ouais tu es l'
éléphant tu n'es pas si mal
laissez tout sortir, c'est imprudent, le
tueur n'hésiterait pas à tuer à nouveau
si cela brouille les pistes,
vous devez être vraiment doué pour l'indice, hein, je suis
très mauvais pour les choses stupides, donner des coups de pied dans des boîtes
en cherchant dans toutes les pièces,
c'est juste un terrible terrible  jeu
étranger
[Musique]